[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
and the series called High School
memories my name is Omar Goshi and I'll
be your host today so without further
ado let's dive into today's episode and
embark on a great journey together get
ready to be engaged entertained and
inspired today's topic will be about
stem a journey into science technology
engineering and Mathematics before we
get into the segments of stem we have to
understand what it stands for it stands
for science technology engineering and
Mathematics it forms the Cornerstone of
our modern world these interconnected
disciplines are not just academic
subjects they are the driving forces
behind Innovation progress and problem
solving and virtually every aspect of
Our Lives science the first pillar of
Stam is all about understanding the
world around us scientists explore the
mysteries of the Universe from the
microscopic world of cells to the
vastness of space they ask questions
conduct experiments and unlock the
secrets of nature technology the second
pillar is the practical application of
scientific knowledge is the reason we
have smartphones computers and the
internet technological advancements
continue continually shape the way we
communicate work and live making the on
unimaginable a part of our daily reality
engineering the third pillar is the art
of applying scientific and mathematical
principles to design and build solutions
to real world problems Engineers are The
Architects of our infrastructures the
Creator creators of bridges buildings
and groundbreaking technologies that
Propel Society
forward mathematics the fourth pillar is
the language of patterns and
relationships it's not just about
numbers it's a tool for logical thinking
and problem solving mathematicians
create the algorithms that power
computer programs analyze data and
unlock the mysteries of the quantitive
world what makes them truly powerful is
the Synergy between these disciplines
scientific discoveries often lead to
technological innovations which
engineers then apply to solve practical
problems stem education is crucial for
preparing the next generation of
thinkers creators and problem solvers it
nurtures curiosity critical thinking and
creativity empowering individuals to
tackle complex challenges whether it's
addressing climate change developing
sustainable Technologies or advancing
medical search
stem provides the tools and mindset
needed to shape a better future as we
navigate the challenges and
opportunities of the 21st century stem
remains at the Forefront guiding us
towards a world shadeed by curiosity and
the transformative power of Science and
Technology the first segment that we're
going to talk about today will be
curiosity curiosity is the driving force
behind exploration and Discovery
Unlocking The Mysteries of the universe
it inspires scientists and thinkers to
ask questions questions seek answers and
push the limits of knowledge curiosity
fuels Innovation across various Fields
fostering a deeper understanding of the
world and sparking creativity nurturing
curiosity ignites a lifelong love for
learning making it a vital force in our
ever evolving understanding of the world
curiosity was the fuel that fueled
Albert Einstein to find to discover the
theory of relativity it fueled Newton to
create calculus and hopefully it will
fuel you and me to create something
useful for
society the SE second segment will be AI
artificial intelligence or AI is like a
Guiding Light in the world of stem which
includes science technology engineering
and math it's here to change the way we
live and work picture this AI can make
decisions and solve complex problems
making things better in areas like
healthare and finance think of it as a
super smart assistant that can predict
diseases accurately by analyzing lots of
data but as we get excited about a more
more efficient world we need to be
careful about the ethical side of AI
when machines start making decisions on
their own it raises big questions about
responsibility fairness and even jobs we
need to find the right balance between
using cool technology and making sure
it's fair and ethical education is also
super important as we bring AI into our
daily lives we must teach people how to
understand and use it stem education
needs to include AI lessons we want
future Generations not just to use AI
but to also create amazing things with
it working together is a big deal for
the future of ai ai is not just about
tech it's a mix of different fields like
engineering data science ethics and
policies in the end the future of AI in
Stam is full of cool possibilities but
also some challenges we have to be smart
and ethical about it it's like having a
superow we want to use it for good to
solve problems and make the world a
better
place the third segment will be
experiments experiments in Stam are like
fun Hands-On Adventures where scientists
and curious minds explore and and learn
new things in science experiments help
us discover how things work imagine
mixing different colors to see what
happens or growing plants to learn more
about nature scientists ask questions
and use experiments to find the answers
Technologies like using cool gadgets and
tools in Stam experiments with
technology might involve coding a
computer program or building a simple
robot it's about making things work and
figuring out how to use technology to
you to solve real world problems
engineering is all about creating and
building Engineers use experiments to
design and test things like Bridges
buildings or even new gadgets it's like
being a problem solver and making things
that help people mathematics the last
part of stem is not just about numbers
it's a tool for solving problems in
experiments maths help us measure and
understand things whether it's counting
measuring or using patterns math is the
secret language that helps us make sense
of the world in other words in other
words math is the language of the
universe experiments in stem are are are
a way for all of these cool subjects to
work together scientists technologists
engineers and mathematicians use
experiments to explore discover and
create it's like being a detective
detective an inventor and an Explorer
all at
once the fourth segment will be about
the beauty of math and physics math and
physics often thought of us abstract and
complex are like artists painting the
canvas of the universe with profound
Beauty let's take a journey into
Aesthetics of these disciplines
exploring the Elegance that underlies
the world we live
in we have different part of beauty of
these part of these two subjects number
one of these will be the dance of
numbers in the world of math there's AR
rithmic dance among numbers shapes and
patterns picture the Symmetry in a
snowflake or the spirals of a sea shell
all Guided by mathematical principles
Math's beauty lies in its ability to
reveal order in apparent chaos providing
a universal language to describe our
world equations the potions The Poets of
relationships bring Harmony to physics
from Newton's law to Einstein theory of
relativity these equations unveil the
structure of the universe it's not just
about predicting it's a Simplicity and
elegance with which they capture complex
phenomena that make them
beautiful the Unseen forces physics
unveils the invisible forces shaping our
reality think of particles dancing at
the quantum level or planets gracefully
orbiting a star the beauty is in the
profound Simplicity governing the
universe fundamental forces
orchestrating a Celestial ballet in the
cosmos Symmetry and Aesthetics symmetry
captivating in both math and physics is
a source of profound pleasure whether
it's the balance of an equation or the
symmetry of a butterfly wings there's
inherent Beauty in the order symmetry
brings to the Natural World The Art of
problem solving in math and physics
problem solving is an art form the joy
of untangling a complex problem or
discovering An Elegant solution is like
creating a masterpiece the beauty lies
not just in finding answers but in the
intellectually Journey uh the
exploration curiosity and the thrill of
Discovery the grand tapestry together
mathematics and physics weave a grand
tapestry telling the story of the
Universe from tiny particles to Cosmic
structures there is a coherence
connecting everything the beauty is in
the interconnectedness seamlessly
blending mathematical Elegance with
physical reality in essence the beauty
of math and physics in is in their
ability to reveal hidden order intricate
patterns and Prof Simplicity underlying
the
universe the uh the last segment for
today will be the future of aerospace
engineering and space exploration in the
vastness of the cosmos Humanity's
journey into the unknown is steered by
the ever evolving field of aerospace
engineering and space exploration as WE
peer into the future the horizons of
these disciplines are expanding
promising unprecedented discoveries and
opportunities that will shape the
destiny of our species the Golden Age of
Aerospace and engineering aerospace
engineering the realm of Designing
aircraft and spacecraft is experiencing
a Renaissance the future holds the
promise of revolutionary materials
Advanced propulsion systems and
aerodynamic breakthrough throughs that
will redefine the possibilities of
flight from supersonic travel to the
development of the Next Generation
spacecraft aerospace engineers are on
the brink of creating vehicles that push
the boundaries of our atmosphere
commercial space travel one of the most
exciting prospects in the future of
aerospace engineering is the roliz of
space travel what was once confined to
government agencies is now becoming
accessible to private companies
commercial space travel is emerging as a
viable industry with companies like
SpaceX blue origin and others colonizing
the cosmos as we gaze towards the future
the concept of human colonizations of
other celestial bodies takes Center
Stage Mars with its red Allure is a
prime candidate of for human settlement
aerospace engineers are actively
developing the techn the Technologies
and infrastructure needed to sustain
life on Mars from life support system to
habitats that can with send the harsh
conditions of the red
planet advancements in the propulsion
systems the propulsion system that
Propel spacecraft through the cosmos are
undergoing a transformative Evolution
ion dri nuclear propulsion and other
Advanced Technologies are being explored
to propel spacecraft faster and more
efficiently space exploration beyond our
solar system the future of space
exploration stands beyond the boundaries
of our solar system Interstellar
missions propelled by ambitious
Technologies like light sails and antim
propulsion are on the drawing board
International collaboration the future
of space exploration is characterized by
unprecedented International
collaborations space agencies from
different countries are pulling their
expertise and resources to tackle Grand
challenges such as establ establishing a
lunar base or conducting joint missions
to explore the mysteries of the universe
the shared vision of exploring space for
the betterment of all humankind is
fostering a new era of cooperation that
transends National borders in conclusion
the future of aerospace engineering and
space exploration is a tapestry woven
with Innovation ambition and Collective
dreams of humanity as we stand on the
precipice of a new era in space
exploration the possibilities are
boundless we've come to the end of this
podcast so in conclusion we understand
that Stam stands for science technology
engineering and math it's a field of
innovation and problem solving it is
waiting to be challenged by us and
future people and hopefully it will grow
and make the world a better place I
would like to thank you so much for
joining us on this episode of high
school memories it's been an incredible
journey and we're so glad you came along
for the ride until next time take
care
[Music]